- [Bertie] Only minutes old,
this harp seal pup is quick to
fall in love with its icy home sweet home.
The ice melts.
In just 10 days time, mom will leave
her behind and never look back.
The countdown begins.
(baby seal cooing)
10, put on at least four pounds per day.
Nine, learn to swim before the ice melts.
Eight, don't panic there
is no time for this.
Seven,
six,
five, four,
three,
two, one.
(wind blowing)
(daunting music)
At first glance the arctic
feel brutally devoid
of life.
Though a select group of animals have
figured out a way to thrive.
(seal pup howls)
But the real force here
works quietly underfoot.
Every winter sea ice
starts small and delicate.
Then it grows over
billions of square miles.
How is it possible that
this freeze up, holds the
key to our entire planet?
Like a lung, sea ice
breathes life into the arctic
every year.
In a cycle that impacts the
climate across the globe.
This is the story from the
edge of the Canadian arctic
where it all starts.
My name is Bertie Gregory and I am a
National Geographic Wildlife Filmmaker.
Everything is at stake, we are all waiting
for the big freeze.
(clock ticking)
(calm music)
Every year, harp seals
leave the rich waters of
the northern Hudson Bay
and join thousands of
other migrating south
out of polar bear range
to their breeding oasis.
A massive ice flow in the
Gulf of St.
Lawrence.
(flute music)
(snow crunching)
It is hard to believe right now,
that we are walking over the ocean.
Everywhere you look as
far as you can see is ice.
That is the reason why I
have got this incredibly
sexy and very fashionable
outfit on and a stick, is 'cause
we want to make sure we
don't fall through a crack in
the ice, into underneath us
which is hundreds of feet
of freezing cold water.
But right now we are looking for what is
arguably the cutest animal on the planet.
(seal pup cries) And I can hear it.
(flute music)
This beautiful little animal,
hello, is a harp seal pup.
It was born here on the ice
about four or five days ago
judging by its size.
It is totally helpless without mom
right now.
(water bubbling) (flute music)
(seal chirping)
In a colony of thousands,
mom needs to make sure she
is not feeding the wrong pup.
Here she comes.
The kiss,
this what harp seals are
famous for,
that kiss is how the mom and pup recognize
each other.
(seals cooing)
This is what that little pup has been
waiting for.
It is dinner time
and it has really
got to make the most of these
feeding sessions because
its has only got 10 days with its mom.
After those 10 days, the female
is going to stop suckling
the pup, and she is going to
head north with the males.
That little pup is going to
be abandoned with nothing
to eat.
So it has really got to build
up its fat reserves now.
Since filming that pup,
I have found something that is
a little bit gross.
So you see down here,
there is this blood trail.
It leads to this.
Now this looks like death
but
it is not, this is life,
this is the placenta.
But it is not actually frozen yet.
That means that somewhere around here,
is a new born pup
that has literally just been born.
I mean that would take
less than an hour to freeze,
so somewhere here, is
that little pup.
Look, there it is.
Yeah, that one is just a few minutes old.
Look how yellow it is
and you can still see
it has got its umbilical cord attached.
You know compared to that
other pup we had which was
only a few days old, four
or five days older, this
shows just how fast they grow
and this little pup
has definitely got some catching up to do.
(tribal music)
You know it is really cool
to see such a young pup
but it is actually not a good thing.
This one is four or five
days behind the rest and
these adults are already
in a race against time
to raise their pups before
the ice breaks up so
this one has an extra big challenge ahead.
(violin music)
(seal pup whimpers)
(violin music) [Bertie]
Our changing climate is
making early ice breakups
more and more common.
In five of the
past ten years
bad ice meant the colony failed to
raise pups.
In 2017
the ice broke up so early
that the entire colony
of pups drowned overnight.
(fast violin music)
So you can see what was
once a giant solid sheet is
now breaking up and the ice
is really on the move, you
can see it.
Here now, it is the time for
these pups to learn to swim
because soon these chunks
are going to get smaller and
smaller and uh, and yeah
they will be forced to swim.
So it is swimming time they got to go.
And that is exactly
what is on this mothers
mind right now.
This real chunky monkey is
so fat it is unbelievable
the amount of change
just in a few days from
that tiny little new born,
now to a big fat sausage.
So we are going to hang out
and see if mom encourages it
for its first swimming lesson.
(cello music)
(seal pup cooing)
(seal pup whimpers)
Are we good to go?
- [Cameraman] Yeah
(flute music)
(seal pup cries)
- [Bertie] Look how she
is using her giant belly
as a big swim float
to help her pup breathe.
You can see she is so
protective of it in the water.
And anytime any of the
other adults come anywhere
near her she chases them
off so aggressively.
It is really doing it, its swimming.
Look at it go.
(flute music)
How incredible must it be to realize
you are actually built for the very medium
that was so daunting just minutes ago.
Now that the mother knows
her pup has the skills to
survive the ice breakup,
it is time for the
hardest lesson of all.
Saying goodbye.
(seal pup howls)
The male harp seals are
now gathering nearby.
Ready to mate with the females.
Okay, getting in.
It is time for the adults to
join and head to the north.
(seals chirping)
(violin music)
We have met truly extraordinary animals on
this adventure.
surrounded by the pack.
Their lives governed by
ticking clocks getting them
to run further, fly faster or swim deeper.
But the thing that ties
them and us together is the
planets loudest ticking clock.
The arctic sea ice.
The big freeze used to give
us millions of square miles of
sun reflecting surface,
stabilizing the earth's climate.
Over just the last thirty
years, we have lost more
than a third of that sea ice.
Now rather than reflecting the suns heat,
open water absorbs it.
And we are witnessing its deadly effects.
(violin music)
But there is hope
and it lies with harnessing
clean energy, using our
land more efficiently and reforesting.
Saving polar bears go beyond
just a nice thing to do,
we are also saving ourselves.
It really is in our hands
whether we want this place to
exist in the future.
Now is really a turning point.
Do we let it go or
do we really band together
to make sure that it
survives into the next century?
(orchestral music)
(piano music)